We are recording. So if you have questions that you don't want to talk on here, you don't have to share your name and make sure you get them to me prior to some people did give me some questions to talk about.
Hopefully I'll get to them today too. So first of all, open it up to questions. We're going to be talking about detoxification today.
We're going to be talking about the biopterid pathway today. So any questions before we get started.
I have one Dr. Connor.
I'm having trouble staying asleep because the wires of the tube are getting all wrapped up in wrapped up around you.
I'm having my pillow in my husband. And so we've tried different several things. We've tried putting them under the covers, under the sheets.
But so my question is this.
Does it have does the bold hammer bulb actually need to be touching my body? I guess I'm not quite certain how the radio frequencies work.
Yeah, no, the hammer the bulb does not need to be touching your body.
It could go through a sheet so you could put the you could put the bulb underneath your fitted sheet. If that helps.
And it will go through the fitted sheet just fine.
Just going to give you a layout on how we do it. Maybe you're doing it this way. You're still getting a little tangled on our right machine itself is underneath our bed.
And then the USB cord obviously goes up to the laptop, which the laptop is sitting on my bed stand on the top of the bed stand.
The wires coming out of the front of the right machine going to the bulb are underneath the bed.
So we will ever catch our foot on them or anything like that. And then they just run up behind our bed and between our headboard and our mattress and the bulb lies between us in the bed.
And then right now, it just lying between us when my wife was dealing with the throws of melanova, she cut she kind of struggled to bulb up next to her.
If if any, either one of us are dealing with anything like a cold or a flu on comed or something, we're ready to program like that, then we'll struggle the bulb bulb next to to be your her.
So, the interesting question I had somebody else today asked if they they taped the wires together and then they called Micah true life and Mike said you don't want to tape the wires together because it could decrease the intensity of the output.
So you want them the wires, you don't have to like purposely keep them apart but you don't want to tape them or buy them together.
Okay.
Which that's the first time I've heard that before with nobody's ever brought that up.
So if that helps, I mean, we'd never get tangled in the court. So if if that layout the way I describe it helps.
And you're not doing it that way, that might solve your problem right there.
Okay.
Good. Any other questions?
It's Jan Smith calling. How are you?
Good. How are you?
Excellent. I have four grandchildren here, so I'm going to make this really real fast.
The black seed human oil.
Two teaspoons a day.
Do I do I take that first thing with my with my vitamin D and my MSM?
I would split them into two doses though.
Good. That's what I'm doing.
But do I take it first thing even before my before my for your shake?
You you can. There's not there's not any research out that at all.
Okay.
So I would think might be good. I know I've had other people just throw it at your shake.
But it is an oil and it could stick to the sides and you could lose some of it.
Okay.
So for conservation purposes, it might be better to just go to teaspoon right when you wake up and go to teaspoon right when you go to bed.
That might be bad. That might be better. It doesn't taste bad or anything.
You could chunk it and drink it and chase it.
But I like tree mark.
So I eat tree mark every day.
So everything's relative, right?
So you keep choking it out.
No, no, it's not a problem. I just didn't I just thought it should be spread out, but I just thought I would confirm that.
Yeah, I think that would be best.
Any other questions?
One more quick question.
Could I put a put a drop of the oil and a drop of DMSO and spread it on the tumor?
To absorb through the skin?
Yeah, you could. That'd be a good try. Yeah, that'd be something fun to try.
Oh, awesome. Okay.
Yeah.
So that brings up another question. Can you experiment with some things like this?
Some what she said for person has breast cancer. That's close to the skin.
Could they experiment with making their own salves like that?
My answer is absolutely.
I, you know, you know, all I do is taking research and trying to extrapolate that for you guys.
And I've taken my experience of doing that same thing and experimenting and extrapolating that for you guys.
And I learned just as much from you when you do things like that.
As you do for me, so there isn't data on all of this information.
So, you know, if you feel like the Holy Spirit's leading you to do something, you know, run it by me.
For sure, if you want to, but don't feel bad about trying to experiment with something like that.
You might want to run things by me so that you don't put something on you.
I'm going to open and move that.
It's like crazy and you wish you'd ever did it, but certainly you could experiment with things like that.
Any other questions?
Dr. Connor, where do you get DMSO at?
So, DMSO is easily purchased out of Amazon.
It is a liquid though.
So it's, it's, it's like water.
So, DMSO used to be really big in the 70s and 80s for paid and arthritis.
You could make it at home, used to be able to make it with some stuff that you have under your kitchen sink.
I don't remember everything that was in it.
That's my methyl sulfoxide, I think, is the technical name for it.
And it was touted as this great, fantastic thing, right?
I don't use DMSO for really so much of the benefits of DMSO.
I use DMSO because it is so readily absorbed.
I use it as a carrier.
So, I have DMSO cream that has, that's an aloe base cream,
a little bit of rose oil in it and DMSO in it that I use, that I put curcubin and sometimes blood root in it to use as a salve for different things, especially for basil cell and squamous cell cancers.
You could also use it for, you know, skin eruptions and things like that.
But you could, if you add, if you use DMSO that you purchase on Amazon, it's very, it's a liquid.
So, you could mix other things in it, but it would have to be a liquid.
Or you could mix it with like a shea butter cream to make a paste and just maybe use a teaspoon of DMSO with a tablespoon of so of shea butter cream.
Mixing it together really good. So now you got a shea butter DMSO.
So there's different things you could do with that to start to make your own different SAV applications.
Then you might use whatever else you want to use to try to drive, use DMSO as the driver to drive it to the, into the tissue like curcubin or some other anti-inflammatory or cancer killer.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Okay. So let's jump into this topic, the myopterid pathway.
So the myopterid pathway, is it specifically a cancer pathway by any stretch of the imagination.
But it does affect our life big time because this is how you make neurotransmitters.
And this is the myopterid pathway right here.
And your neurotransmitters are serotonin right here.
You can see my screen, right?
Okay, dopamine, epinephrine and or epinephrine.
So these are four major neurotransmitters, the one that's not out here because it's not made through the myopterid pathway as glutamate, which we spoke a lot of, I think last week, which is so essential.
But it comes to cancer and we'll touch on that when we talk about these genes.
Now this pathway is run just like everything else.
Genes make enzymes to make these different things and to push these different pathways.
So fetalality, tyrocytid, triptophane, and arginine are amino acids that you get in your diet when we protein.
And they go through these different genes to make aldopa, to make dopamine, tyrocytid.
Here's tyrocytid again, makes aldopa, to create triptophane, to make 5-HTP, to make serotonin, and that's broken down.
And then triptophane goes this way through the chiroid pathway too.
So not to get too technical, but serotonin is important to have balance of these neurotransmitters.
So this could be a little oversimplified.
Like, oh, serotonin is good, that's your feel good neurotransmitter, that's what keeps you happy.
That's your happy neurotransmitter.
Not really, not really at all.
If it's in balance, it is, yes, two little serotonin.
So if I have defects on this gene right here, this Mao gene, that two little serotonin is going to cause all sorts of problems in my life.
So this Mao gene, there's more than just one, but this is an old slide.
Hold serotonin in the brain.
Defects on it can cause excess serotonin or two little serotonin.
So symptoms of two little serotonin are going to be melancholy issues, just real sadness.
And, well, of course, we could be sad due to circumstances.
But if we kind of feel like we're in a pit or in a rot and we can't get out of that rot, we do want to look at neurotransmitters.
So here would be a perfect case of point.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I'm in this rot.
I've kind of always had slight depression my whole life.
And lately I have a lot more depression.
I don't know what's better with me.
Well, let's look at your genes.
You have a bunch of Mao gene defects.
So it's quite possible that serotonin is just shooting down this pathway and you're, you're writing it right out.
So you're not holding serotonin in the brain.
And therefore you have a lot of depression.
So let's look, let's go back up stream of what feeds serotonin, how you could help that person.
Well, you could use a dietary component where we could add, we could add protein to their diet.
And that would help feed serotonin this way.
But if there are cancer patients, we don't want the glutamates that are in the protein as these are amino acids that will be in proteins.
But also glutamates and other amino acids are in protein that we might not want for a cancer patient.
We could use five HTTP to feed that pathway.
So you just go back up stream.
How can we help feed that pathway to help that person with depression?
And we could go right here and use a, use a supplementation program with adding this.
As a problem is you got to be careful because oh, I do have kind of some sadness.
So I'm going to get on some five HTTP.
Well, if you do that.
And you push this pathway too hard, you could have excess serotonin.
It will cause depression.
But too much causes aggression, short fuse, short tempered, get angry quickly.
And nobody likes that in their spouse.
So defects on this gene can cause it to go too fast or cause it to go too slow in its breakdown process.
And leave the patient at different times with two little serotonin and sadness.
And at other times with too much serotonin and they're going to bite somebody's head off.
So you have to be careful pushing the pathway.
So you don't want to go, oh, well, I read this is good for this.
So I'm going to take this one could be the wrong thing to do.
The other thing is that depression isn't always caused solely from low serotonin.
Depression could be, could be from what's called a trip to fan steel where trip to fans being stolen off through this, especially if the person's got IDO gene defects.
Or they have a chronic infection like live or anything else.
That pushes this pathway and they develop a whole bunch of this bad guy, this quintaletic acid.
And that causes depression big time.
So more of the people that are really strongly with depression, it's going this way.
So feeding the HTTP this way is the wrong thing to do because now they're depressed and they're biting off your head.
So now they're a really not fun person to be with and this is their fourth relationship.
So you have to look at all these genes, what you're assessing that in a person.
So I know most people come to me because they have Lyme and they have cancer.
But as we start to melonose things out and you start to we're working on those things, then we can start addressing some of this other stuff that could be really helpful.
So same thing with dopamine.
Dopamine is fed through tyrosine here to make dopamine.
It goes through about the mao gene as well, but more frequently through the cup gene.
So this gene is affected also with dopamine with hydrogen peroxide.
That's why I'm not a fan of hydrogen peroxide as a therapy.
So because that blocks that gene, it could cause a lot more ADD, ADHD symptoms in a person.
So symptoms of access dopamine.
Dopamine is your driver, neural transmitter.
So person that has cup gene defects, let's look at where the comp gene is right here.
People with these defects tend to be as youngsters have a lot of ADD, ADHD.
They tend to be maybe a little bit more problem students.
Because it's very difficult for them to stay focused because their dopamine is just like, I got to fight them.
Oh, I got to do some different. Oh, there's a squirrel.
And so it's hard to stay focused.
But as an adult, these people tend to be the entrepreneurs.
They tend to be the company leaders. They tend to be maybe not the best employees, but they tend to own their own businesses.
And they tend to get a lot of things done.
You look at the history of anybody like Steve Jobs and those kind of people.
They definitely had a lot of comp gene defects.
So I am not a person who is in the favor, I am used to see a lot of ADD, ADHD kids, and you look at their genetics.
And this is what their genetics look like right there.
I've got the favor of necessarily tried to change that because that's my genes right there too.
So I think there's going to be advantages if you harvest it in the right way.
But it could be good to not feed that pathway too hard.
So if you have a child with ADD, ADHD, it's fed through tyrosine.
You know, these kids tend to be that are that I have these these comp gene defects make you can get basically addicted to dopamine.
So these kids, you know, in excess, these people could be thrill seekers could do dangerous things.
And that can be harmful to them.
If you took your child that had those symptom patterns and you decreased their protein, literally just you're getting a half a piece of chicken instead of a whole chicken breast, and you have to eat your squash more squash or more whatever.
So if you cut their protein in half, you can see a dramatic change in the temperament of the child.
I had one little one parent who had it adopted.
I told this story in one of my other genetic slides presentations.
They adopted this little kid that had his genes were the one of the worst I've ever seen is brought by after pathway and he was literally climbing the walls.
Or literally like this kid's going to be imprisoned by time he's six years old.
Kids get this under control.
And we literally cut out protein completely from his diet and the parents came in and said, we've never met this kid before.
He's like a totally different child.
So you can have dramatic change in their person's temperament.
So we're talking about neurotransmitters.
We're talking about temperament.
We're talking about ability to focus.
We're talking about ability to think.
We're talking about how your brain's working or also talking about muscle contraction and and you know you need neurotransmitters everywhere.
Those that you have two neurons that connect.
Not just in your brain.
So looking at the pathway, looking at the genes, looking at the substrates, meaning what forms that end product.
You can help help guide the patient through issues that they're having and solve a lot of their problems.
So if that is you, if I've struck a chord with any of you, we just contact us and schedule a time that we could look at your genes in a little bit different light that way.
Because there's other things that we could do to help a person other than just looking at it from, you know, being so bioptic with just cancer or live or whatever your going through specifically.
Also, you can't do a neurotransmitter test.
I don't do many of these anymore, but you can test a person's neurotransmitter and see where they're at.
The reason why I'm not super keen on this is because this changes day by day.
So it's not the most specifically accurate test, but it does give you kind of a hint of where we're off.
And it can help a patient deal with that in some ways.
But balancing those neurotransmitters can be extremely helpful.
The glutamate is a neurotransmitter too.
And remember glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter in your brain.
It is necessary, even though we've speak when we talk about glutamate with cancer, we speak about it in such negative terms.
But it is a necessary neurotransmitter.
It's what wakes you up in the morning.
It's what keeps you focused.
People with a higher intelligence tend to have higher glutamate levels.
But you have to make sure it's all about balance too.
The GAD defects cause you to have excess glutamate.
BHM-T-O-A to the CBS-699 defects cause you to create excess glutamate.
So the GAD gene is how you break down glutamate to GABA, which GABA is a call made neurotransmitter.
And that's necessary to do that.
So people that have a lot of defects are their GAD genes.
They have difficulty going to sleep, stay to sleep.
Their rate is just racing.
People with excess glutamate tend to have a lot more OCD-like characteristics.
And tend to be much more perfectionistic, can't let things go.
They perseverate on thoughts, even warriors.
This is a huge issue with cancer.
Or any serious disease, if, you know, I've said this over and over with,
is if I can't get my cancer patients to get to a point of just, hey,
this is what it is, I'm going to do everything I possibly can.
But I'm putting this in the hands of my heavenly father.
And I'm, and I'm going to let it go.
I'm not, I'm not that I'm going to be ignorant.
Stick my head in the sand and not learn more.
But I can't stay stuck in perseveration of thought of warrior.
What if what happens?
And that is very detrimental.
So that will produce even more glutamate.
So you have to get control of your thoughts.
So many of these things.
So we're talking about physiological pathways.
But physiological pathways.
Most of them are governed by what's called a negative feedback loop.
So if I'm birding dopamine, because I'm doing things that are dopamine related,
meaning I'm doing risky things and, and speeding down the highway.
And I'm going to, um, into risky behavior.
I will become basically addicted, not truly addicted,
but I will draw and create more dopamine.
I will actually crave more protein to make more dopamine to, to feed that pathway.
Because I'm birding dopamine.
So I'm basically, it's acting like a vacuum.
I'm sucking in more and I'm craving more.
It's the same thing with glutamate.
It's the same day, perseverating a thought, and worried, and anxious,
and upset, and then I will make more glutamate.
And it's this whole negative feedback.
It's a negative cycle, but it works on that negative feedback loop.
So I've birdied it, so I got to need more.
So it's a dangerous situation to be in.
That's why I think scripture is very clear.
You have to take captive every thought.
You have to use to, to harness this and to make it productive.
And to be as thoughtful about your thoughts as you possibly can, you know,
purposely take control of these things and change your habit.
Now, I understand what you have a lot of issues.
It's difficult to do that.
You need some help.
And that's why I just understanding that wow, I'm feeding this.
I'm just not feeding the beast, and it will help a lot.
So glutamate is also fed by amino acids, but not these amino acids.
It's fed by glutamate.
So cutting back on protein a little bit is better in that circumstance,
if you're dealing with glutamate too.
So these are some more of the glutamate genes that we look at.
And the pathways that we look at it, I won't get into the EOS genes.
We'll save that until next week.
Does that bring up any questions or concerns for anybody?
I do have a question about this Dr. Conner.
I have several people in my life that are telling me, oh, we've got to go get surgery and.
I'm not quite certain how to handle them.
One of them specifically is in her 10th round of chemotherapy.
And I just need some words of wisdom as what to say to them.
I mean, I wrote down what you just said about putting in the hands of our Heavenly Father.
And I totally believe that, but sometimes it gets overwhelming.
They think they're being nice to me, but it gets to the point where I'm avoiding people now.
I suggest you go, you go and you read the book of Galatians.
Because that had, honestly, that has helped me a lot to deal with people that disagree with.
I just started it this morning.
So, um, and that the truth is from a psychological standpoint,
people want you to do what they're doing because it justifies what they're doing.
And if you're doing what they're, even if they're running off of a cliff and jumping off of a cliff,
as long as there's more people doing it, then they feel good about.
So, and I'm not saying that what that person is doing is wrong for her or him.
It's that, but when, when, when, when someone is judging you.
You can feel it, can't you?
And so make sure that you're not judging other people.
Don't judge them that they're doing the wrong thing.
Because you're going to be judged the same way.
Okay.
So just go, hey, whatever is right for you that you should do that.
But don't judge me on what I'm doing.
I really respect that or we're going to have to distance ourselves from each other a little bit during this process.
Um, there isn't anything wrong with doing that.
If that person is really a real friend, they'll, you know, apologize and they'll respect your decision.
And if they're, if they're so insecure about their decision making process, they're going to be more app to pressure you to do what they're doing.
Because that will give them more security.
So it's really coming from that person's insecurity.
But it still doesn't feel good.
Uh, so I understand that.
So you're, you're just going to, you might have to have a talk with that person.
If they're close, if they're a family member that you, that they're not, that they're always going to be in your life.
If they're not a family member that's going to be not in your life.
And you could, you know, move them, move that relationship a little, make a little distance in that relationship.
It might be the best thing to do.
Okay. Thank you.
The biggest thing is you want to respect everybody's decision, because it's their decision.
And when you, when we stop judging other people, then we're not judged with that same judgment.
Um, but even when we stop judging other people, people could be judging us.
But those are people that maybe we either have a talk with and say, you know, you're judging me on the decision I'm making.
You need to respect my decision, or we need to not talk so much.
And, and, um, if they're truly a friend and they're truly mature, then they should be able to handle that.
If not, then, then maybe, maybe it was time to say goodbye for a while.
So, um, that would be by opinion.
So.
Thank you.
Anything else.
Well, hopefully these are helpful for everybody.
If you have questions that you want addressed on here, you can email them.
If I don't get them email me again next week, you got, I understand we get like 200 emails a day.
So, so sometimes they get gets buried real quick.
So, um, but even put put in the in the title or whatever that's called on the email, put it in, uh, put a zoom call questions.
So that I will get to those.
Um, all right, so I probably will have another zoom call this week and I'll post it on Facebook because I missed last week.
And there's some new stuff that I want to go over about about some other stuff that I'm studying.
So I'll put it some slides together and we'll go over that.
Everybody have a blessed day. This will be recorded it up on Facebook. If you want to listen to it again.
And if you do have questions about anything emotionally that you're going through that you want me to look at your jeans.
This way, then make sure you just call the office and set up time.
Oh, thanks so much.
Oh, you bet. All right.
We will edit here. Bye.